hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial this one is going to be by
request obviously you can see by the
title up above on how to use and
basically a tutorial on the program
called skype which is basically as mayor
of silver i p program uh our application
where you can actually call
and
not well you can actually call and have
video conferences and chats skype users
for free
and it's very very quick to use so here
i'm going to show you how to use it
first thing you have to do is download
skype from skype.com i won't even put in
this i'll put it in the description but
it's very very simple skype.com and once
you have it you'll have a shortcut on
your desktop and just drag it to your
rocket docker or your shortcut
down here wherever you want to add it
basically just click on it to start it
and over here as you can see i already
have a chat going with the person who
actually requested the video who was
actually begging me to do the video so
i'll open up his youtube i'll put his
youtube page in the description go check
out his vids he has about a dozen vids
and they're really good
so uh this right now is the skype chat
application which is very simple and uh
demonstrating it all you have to do you
can see you can emoticons
um you can change your logo you can
personalize your entire skin
as well as change a whole bunch of other
things about skype so first of all i'll
get into chatting all you have to do is
type a
message
and he will get the message and the next
thing you'll see is at the top if he
begins to respond there will be a little
pen drawing exactly well it won't be
drawing what he's writing but it'll
actually be drawing um next you can go
into the actual skype application by
clicking it in your doc or not your doc
oh here you go this is his response
double question mark
so
going into the actual skype application
when you open it it's going to look like
this you'll have a file button an
account button a call button
a chats button a view toolbar tools and
help now i won't actually go through the
entire thing but when you change your
online status it basically shows what
people how you show up in your contact
list which is right here
so here's the contacts tab
i have a lot of contacts that are not
online right now obviously but right now
he is online and i have best buy and
staples as two of my site contacts
because i've called them already
if you want to add a skype contact for
texting them or um
video messaging them or anything at any
time just hit that little add button
right there and type in their name
and sure enough you'll find them in here
obviously there's a ton of people with
the word name in their name
so yeah
now
another thing that i like to do with
skype is called calling
and i won't actually demonstrate skype
calling but you just have to hit that
button right there that green cell phone
looking button
and
that's exactly what it'll do call that
person now if they don't have a built-in
mic it's not going to work very well
obviously if they do have a built-in mic
then it'll open up their their
microphone and you'll actually get to
talk to each other just like you're on
the phone and i'll actually do a a
little review on skype 4 which will show
you how to upgrade that quality and
upgrade the instantaneousness of
chatting with someone almost like
they're really there so i have dual
microphone so that's going to sound a
lot better in skype three and four
so also under the file button you can
edit and personalize your profile such
as changing your avatar which you see
whenever i call you or i'm in your
contact list so that is omar's avatar
right there and you can click on the i
at any time to get his info
also under tools you can add a contact
search for other skype users and import
contacts from other instant messaging
clients like aim trillion whatever you
may use yahoo messenger
also a cool thing is you send money by
paypal send sms messages this is all
just by the free by the way the free
version of skype you can also buy uh
skype credits actually call landlines to
call
other people's cell phones straight from
your pc
but skype to other skype users is very
very simple and it is completely free
the last thing i want to show you guys
is how i personalize my page so i'm
going to go
into here and hit the personalize button
now i'm going to change my picture right
now it's that mkb icon all you have to
do is go to browse
and find the picture you want and then
it open and it will that will be the
picture or you can take a video snapshot
using your webcam that's a nice way to
just set an actual picture of you
as your uh as your skype logo
so
yeah this is his status also this button
right here will open up video calling
which is really nice feature if you have
a very if you have a video camera or a
web camera that you've hooked up to your
pc where it's built in
and you have a microphone then you can
do video calls at any time and um
obviously i can't down i can't um
i can't actually uh demonstrate that for
you guys but here it's version version
3.8 i'm going to do a video on how to
uh upload or how to increase uh how do i
say this on how to upgrade to version
4.0 of skype so
basically that is the basic overview of
skype and again his uh youtube page will
be in the description and go ahead and
subscribe to his channel
and um that's basically you guys
so
skype is basically a really nice
freeware feature and again i'll put the
skype.com link in the description
and you can
you can do download chats
etc so i really like the interface of
skype send them files you can send them
contacts you can send them all sorts of
things so i like this option you can set
um you can just there's a whole ton of
things you can do to customize skype and
i'll definitely do another vid on this
so guys thanks for watching my hd
tutorial hope you like it if you have
any other video tutorials or ideas
obviously at the top you see this was a
request there are tons of things that i
will do videos on if you requested
thanks for watching guys peace